[Music]
hello everyone today we will be taking a
look at docker it is one of the hottest
technologies in the DevOps space right
now okay let's take a look at the agenda
will answer the question what is docker
we will discuss why we need docker
docker versus VMS we'll look at docker
hub and we'll go over the docker basic
commands we'll discuss
docker images and we'll see the docker
demo so what is docker docker is
basically a container engine and it
allows you to run your applications
inside containers now until now we've
been running our applications in virtual
machines every virtual machine used to
be the base of our application but now
with the advent of docker and
containerization technologies each
application is run in a container like
logical space so to define a container
it is a logical grouping of all the
binaries and all the dependencies that
each application requires and then
bundling it into a single hole and
running it on top of a docker engine
docker is typically used to run
applications typically like micro
servers which are single bundled
applications now they don't really
depend on a lot of external factors now
the benefit of having applications in
containers is that you don't really need
to worry about the base infrastructure
you just need to make sure that you have
the docker engine running and that will
make sure that the container is running
in the same way on any platform docker
is open source so you don't need to pay
to use docker at least the open source
version or the Community Edition the
Enterprise version has been recently
launched and it is a few more features
but I have seen many projects
implemented with the open source version
and it is more than enough for what you
need to get your basic applications
containerized when we talk about docker
it's kind of like a mini platform as a
service so in a normal platform as a
service offering what you guys just the
actual thing that you need to run so
let's say you're using elastic beanstalk
on Amazon Web Services and you get a
ruby platform on which you can run your
application now with docker you get a
real platform but just the platform
required to run your application and
that is more than enough to get yourself
into production dr integrates easily
with other tools so it integrates with
other ecosystem tools
warm which is a cluster management
system it integrates with monitoring
systems you can monitor things on the
user ports using na Dios or any other
monitoring system you've been using
within your existing infrastructure you
can monitor the base hosts in docker on
which docker actually runs using your
normal monitoring tools so why do we
need it what is the benefit of using
docker we're really good on VMs and
we've been running them for the last
decade so what's the real need to go to
docker well the first thing is you get
really efficient utilization of your
resources now let's say I've got 10 VMs
and I'm running 10 applications on VMs
and things are good but the only problem
is VM number 4 is at 50% utilization so
I'm actually wasting half of capacity on
VM number 5 and I'm beyond number 6 say
I'm just using 40% of the entire power I
have so in that case a lot of the
provisioned of capacity goes to waste
now in order to use that space and
capacity in a more efficient way you
need to have some sort of mechanism
which abstracts the base hardware
allocation and the application now
docker forms the best combination for
that so it allows you to run your
applications and containers and at the
same time allows you to optimize your
resource utilization so let's say you're
on 10 VMs earlier and you were running
10 applications and when you move to
docker and you've doctor eyes your
applications you can use those same ten
VMs and on top of those VMs run a
cluster of docker containers and those
10 VMs now will be available as a whole
to docker swarm or any other cluster
management system and you can run all
your applications across those ten
containers so when in fact those ten VMs
would be available as a whole for the
containers to easily run anywhere you
can actually bump in more containers on
the same number of VMs so let's say you
were on 50% utilization and you want to
increase the utilization and you can
actually run more containers so you
could actually get up to 90% utilization
of the same hardware so with this you
easily get scalability since you can
scale up or scale down any cluster
management system so if you're running
docker swarm for example you can scale
up your containers to any number just by
a single command you get the portability
of the cloud as well as docker
containers let's say you are on AWS
cloud and you want to move to Google
cloud you can import your containers to
Google Cloud
just by running a swarm cluster there
and then porting the image and that's it
you don't need to worry about any
networks for anything else you just run
your application on top of docker swarm
or docker engine now with this
portability you get the advantage of
having multiple environments and with
those multiple environments you can have
disaster recovery in place disaster
recovery will give you a high
availability and your business will
never be down that's one of the biggest
advantages of docker and you can easily
set up dr zones and in your environment
now let's compare docker with VMs
Dockers fast you can run a docker
container like in one hundred and
twentieth of a second whereas a VM takes
almost three minutes to boot up if it's
a gooey VM if it's a CLI VM it takes
almost a minute and a half to boot up so
docker containers are lightweight since
they follow the layer filesystem
approach any docker container which is
like a base image would be around 120 to
150 megabytes now if you look at a VM
OVF file or a VMDK file from VMware
you'll find that it's almost 2 gigabyte
for the CLI version and for the gooey
version it's more than 4 gig docker
containers are portable you can easily
port them by committing them to a docker
hub and then importing them elsewhere
VMS are not that portable so let's say
you've got a vm in a VMware sphere in
your house and you really have to import
that entire image using a pin drive or
some sort of network share and it takes
like 4 or 5 hours to do the transfer so
the portability aspect for the VMS is
less desirable let's talk about docker
hub just like you have github for code
there is docker hub for docker
containers now docker hub is used to
store docker images and share them as
well with the community docker hub has
both open source and pay repositories so
it's an open repository managed by
docker
inclusive so they have it for the
community so you can get one private
repository and unlimited public
repositories for free on the docker hub
you've got official images of almost
every software on earth like Ingenix
Apache 2 Enterprise Edition images
it's a hosted solution for private repos
so if you pay docker hub for private
repositories you can get a cloud hosted
solution there so you don't need to
manage a local repository in your
infrastructure there are some docker
basic commands which we will take a look
at in the demo there is a docker PS that
is used to show how many containers are
running docker pull which allows you to
see and pull images from the docker hub
docker run is used to run docker
containers docker images will show you
the images you have in your local
repository docker attached will attach
to the shell of a running container
docker stop will stop a running
container and we'll start a stopped
container let's take a look at the demo
so I've got a Linux machine here on a
boon to 16.04 command line version
machine ready set up it's running on a
virtual box and I'll be using the
terminal on my macbook to access the
machine we'll proceed with the
installation of docker on that machine
first of all then we'll pull some images
from the docker hub we will also try to
run some containers and then we will
look at the usage of some normal
commands then we will try to make some
changes in the image and commit to the
local repository and push it to the
docker hub so that will be all for the
demo
[Music]
so this is my boon to 1604 image so you
see LSB underscore release - a you see
it's a boon - sixteen point oh four
codenamed xenial and it's the latest LTS
release will be using apt first of all
to install a couple of dependencies
which docker has so I'll say apt-get
install apt - transport
HTTP
- certificates
curl
- common - properties - why
you
the - why is used as a yes to
automatically accept the agreement
pretty much all of these are there by
default in the installation of a boon
tube so you don't really need to worry
about those but just as a security check
we did that
now the next step we are going to
download the GPG key of docker from the
official repository so they hosted at
download docker calm the reason we need
to have that is that we want to make
sure we don't get any spoofed packages
so we do a curl - f
so I'm doing it in the silent mode using
these switches because I'm going to pass
that the apt - key add the command it's
hosted on HTTP download docker calm
forward slash Linux forward slash and
boon to four slash GPG and I'll pipe it
to the apt key command so I'll say apt -
key add - so what this will do is get
the GPG key from the docker repository
and add it to the local apt cache
okay
okay have pressed it as you'd say okay
so this means the key is added now now I
want to add the repository for the
docker installation there's a remote but
my local installation doesn't know
there's a remote repository so I'll be
using the add - apt - repository command
to do that so I'll say add - apt -
repository to do that
then I'll say Deb are equals and be 64
[Music]
HTTP download docker comm / linux / boon
- then dollar LSB release - CS
and then stable
this command will add the
straight to my EDC apt sources.list so
if I open the file and etc' apt if I
open the sources that list file you'll
see
so I've added the amd64 which is the
64-bit version since my machine is
64-bit so if I do a you name - a it says
x86 64 so I want a 64-bit machine and
that's why I've added a 64-bit
repository of docker next step I want to
do is update my apt caches because I
want to get the latest package indexes
so I'll say apt - get update - why
after updating the local cache I need to
restore the docker Community Edition so
I'll use the apt command again apt-get
install docker - see - why this will
install the docker Community Edition on
my local machine it will fetch all the
repository packages
you
now Dockers installed on this machine
let me check and see what version of
docker I have so I'll do docker - -
version so you see I have doctor version
17 point O 3.1 Community Edition build
c64 12 e the next thing I need to do is
I need to go and run a HelloWorld
container because that's like a health
check
so I'll say docker run hello - world do
a couple of health checks in the
background now you see it says unable to
find the image locally polling
filesystem layer from docker hub and it
gives me this nice clean output that
says hello from docker this message
shows that your installation appears to
be working correctly to generate this
message dr. took the following steps so
basically I did a whole lot of health
checks in the backend to contact dr.
Damon then the docker hub was contacted
the image was downloaded so everything
seems to be fine now now I'm going to
download a couple of images there so the
first thing you do is you search for
those images so I'll search for the
Ubuntu image so I'll say docker search a
boon to
so you see a lot of images are out there
of which only the first one is an
official one so you see this is official
okay so I'll download all four major
versions so I'll say docker
pull Kubuntu this will pull the doctor a
boon to image
you
so you see it's pulling down the layers
I'll pull the fedora image these are the
four most popular versions so I'll say
docker full
Fedora
you
docker pull Debian
you
and then dr. pol sent us
that's the fourth one
so all of these images have been pulled
from the docker hub let me give you a
quick look at the docker hub so if you
go to hub docker com
you go to explore you'll see almost
every major software is in there
Ingenix Redis busybox Ubuntu Alpine
registry my sequel [ __ ] glasses search
a log stash node hello world to be
everything so I've pulled four images
here so if I do a docker images it will
list out all the so in addition to the
hello world I've got four more images
which I've pulled down so you see it
shows me the tags which is the latest
there's an image which corresponds to a
unique image ID on the docker hub it
shows me they've created eight six days
ago twelve days ago
whatever date image was created and the
size so you see the size is considerably
small 119 Meg 100 Meg the hello world is
just 1 KB CentOS is just 193 and be
Fedora is 231 MB the next thing we're
going to do is I want to run the
containers so let me run the Kubuntu
container so I'll say docker run - TI
Ubuntu so this will run the docker a
boon to image in interactive mode so
I'll be able to switch to this container
so you see the prompt will change now to
route at 480 so I'm inside the container
now so I'll do a free - M and the
container has the same amount of memory
as the base machine so let me go to the
base machine so I'll open up a session
to the base machine here okay now in
this image root at this this is the
container if I do a free - here in the
base machine you see almost the same
amount of RAM is free so this means
docker containers use the same RAM that
is available on the base machine now I'm
going to do a docker PS - eh here it
shows me that there are two containers
running one has the hello world
container which I ran four minutes ago
and was used just as a health check and
then you see there's a boon to container
running and its name has been given
randomly by the doctor Damon as happy
past you er so this container is running
in the background and it's up in this VM
now we're going to stop this container
using the docker stop command so I'll
say Dockers stop and then the container
ID this will stop the containers so if I
do a docker PS - eh you see it shows
that it has exited but I can restart
this container by doing a docker start
and then I can attach the command line
of that container using the dr. attached
command you see I've restarted it and I
was able to attach it now let me exit
from this container and let me remove
all the containers so the command to
remove all the containers is docker RM
and then the container ID now you can
see I have one container remaining I've
removed all of them at once by just
doing the docker RM and then in brackets
I'll be placing docker PS - aq which
will get all the container IDs now if
you run it as a standalone you'll see
docker PS - a cube gives you all the
container IDs now let me run one
container in the background once I do
docker run - TI - D boon - so you see
it's running in the background so if I
do a docker PS - a
there's a container agitated Euler
running in the background I can attach
to that container by using the docker
attached command
docker
attached and then the container ID
now let me update this container and
make some changes so I can commit to the
docker hub so I say apt-get update - why
this will update my docker container to
have the latest package indexes from the
Ubuntu repositories
you
now I'll do an app to get so I'll
install the patchy web server on this so
I'll say apt-get install
apache2 - why this will install the
Apache web server I actually on this
container I'm doing this because I want
to save the state of this container on
the docker hub so this is downloading
the apache2 from the remote repositories
then I'll start the Apache service
so I'll say service
gee to start so if I do a service Apache
to
status you will see it is running now
the next thing I want to do here is exit
from this container and then try to
commit it so I'll use the docker commit
command and to save the state of this
container so you see docker PS - eh this
is the container for which I'll save the
state for so I'll say docker commit - M
this is the commit message so I'll stay
installing
Pachi web server
I'll say author named Amir and then
container ID and the name which I won't
put now there's one thing which we need
to take care of here you have to make
sure that your image has the following
formatting it should be your user name
on the docker hub Amir Ahmad 170 slash
whatever your container a has so I'll
say a boon - - Apache - now when I
commit this container it comes into the
local images list so if I do a docker
images you can see it's here now I've
got to push this to the docker hub so
I'll say docker login - you login to the
docker hub from the command line using
my username so I'll say docker - you
emiram ed 170
I'll give it my password so I'm logged
into the docker hub now it says docker
logon succeeded now I can commit that
image so I'll say docker push I've
already committed it so I'll push it now
so I'll say docker push and then the
image ID so if I just do a push here
it's doing this but in the meantime if I
go to my dashboard I already have two
things here and in a moment you'll see
one more here
so it's pushing all the layers of the
image
you
and then once you push this I can just
remove my local thing so when i refresh
this here you'll see a third image
coming up here
actually it has over it in the one I
already had so let me just delete and
reach this
I'm going to clean up my docker hub here
delete
I'll delete this one as well
delete
delete okay now if I push again you'll
see it will create a new image here in
my docker hub it will take some time to
do that but that would be a confirmation
that the image has been pushed from my
docker machine here so it's pushing 137
MB of the image layer the top layer
so you see this is pushed so now the
basic idea behind this pushing was I
really wanted to keep this saved in the
remote docker hub so I'm gonna remove
all my local images so I'll say docker
images ok I'll remove all of them so
I'll say docker first I'll clean up my
container so I'll say docker RM
so there's no container running so I'll
remove all the images locally so I'll
say docker images and then I'll do a
docker
RMI - f
so I'm removing it forcefully
but I'll do the single command remove so
I'll say docker images
- aq this is a single command remove it
basically gets all the image IDs in this
command so let me show you this right
now there is no image but it will put
all those image IDs here and forcefully
remove all those images so if I do a
docker images no docker image is there
if I do a docker PS I have an ape no
container is there now let me run the
container from here so I'll pull the
image first using this command so the
beauty of docker hub is that it gives
you a command for pulling the container
so I'll do docker pull
emiram add 172 slash Ubuntu - Apache
tube so it statically goes to the docker
hub it's pulling the layers from there
you
- TI and then the name of this or
running this in just a moment
I'll be running this in the interactive
mode and once if I do a history you'll
see the command said I ran apt-get
update apt-get install
service of hash you just start servers
Apache to status so this is how you push
images to the docker hub and then pull
them from there
so this is all that we have for docker
thanks for watching this video and have
a nice day
hey want to become an expert in cloud
computing then subscribe to simpler
Channel and click here to watch more
such videos turner it up and get
certified in cloud computing click here